[ Joanne Narrating ]
I didn’t plan to end up in the food business.
I started, right after graduation,
working for a consulting firm.
I left the consulting firm
and got a job at a restaurant...
and then I fell in love with it.
So I came back to Boston
and opened a bakery.
Now I own four bakeries and a restaurant.
When I got to Harvard as a freshman–
I’d always been kind of a math geek
in high school...
so, to me, it seemed natural
to kind of fall into math.
I realized there were so many other things
that I didn’t even know existed...
that I could possibly be interested in.
I think Harvard spends a lot of time
trying to make sure that all of its offerings...
are really enticing
and well put together.
When I first started, there was a whole world
that kind of opened up.
It’s like going to a buffet where there’s
all the best desserts in the world.
You just don’t know where to start.
Would imagine everybody who goes
just takes a moment...
says, “Wow. I thought I was gonna be ‘X’...
but now I could potentially
be ‘Y’ or ‘Z’”...
which is the fun part.
My name is Joanne Chang.
I graduated in ’91, and I lived in Leverett House.